nous sommes à Saint-Maximin dans l'Oise
à 6 m sous terre ici se trouvent des
galeries gigantesques que connaî par
cœur Denis montagne son métier
inspecteur de carrière souterraine voyez
le décollement là il y a une
fracturation naturelle celle-là la
grande là donc c'est la pierre tombale
assurée là si vous passez en dessous le
mauvais jour aujourd'hui sous
surveillance ces carrières sont une
chance incroyable pour les ouvriers de
chantilly à la Renaissance elles sont
situées seulement à 7 km du chantier
grosso modo depuis 2000 ans vous avez
une activité extractive on a la chance
d'avoir un des plus grands sites
carriers de France avec une pierre de
qualité et qui a fourni partout pour
toutes les époque donc il a servi toute
la construction de Paris construction de
Versailles tous les grands châteaux si
ces carrières sont si prisées c'est
qu'elles abritent une pierre d'une
qualité exceptionnelle c'est une pierre
homogène qualité mécanique qui est belle
qui qui est réputé donc elle se taille
bien vous vous la rayz à l'ongle elle se
travaille bien à l'outil elle a a tout
pour plaire quoi une pierre assez blonde
qui qui joue bien avec le soleil
Picardie et puis c'est une pierre qui
permet en effet des sculptures de très
très bonne qualité mais avant de
sculpter la pierre il faut l'extraire à
la Renaissance les ouvriers de Chantilly
n'avaient qu'un seul outil à leur
disposition une sorte de piolet très
rudimentaire vous allez enlever de la
pierre de manière
régulière sous toute la surface que vous
voulez extraire
les tailleurs de pierre répètent alors
l'opération de chaque côté du bloc et à
ce momentl le bloc va se détaché c'est
un travail
éant donc vous avez un rendement pour
quelqu'un qui travaille une dizaine
d'heur par jour d'un m par semaine
sachant que le bâtiment à construire
fait 60 m par 30 m le chantier du Petit
Château prend beaucoup de temps trop au
goût du commanditaire ils sont
toujours sous la pression de finir les
travaux au bon moment parce que le
connéable va venir parce que la Cour va
venir et parfois du coup ils sont
obligés de travailler très vite et
peut-être trop vite pour pouvoir avancer
dans les temps et on voit notamment
qu'une partie de la fondation du petit
château n'est pas très très bien faite
avec des matériaux de récupération qu'on
a mis très très vite en œuvre ça il est
assez probable que c'est une contrainte
pas du tout technique mais que c'est une
contrainte qui est liée à un
commanditaire exigeant qui trouve que le
chantier n'avance pas assez vite ce qui
aura pour conséquence un affaissement du
plancher de 8 cm 5 siècles plus tard
toujours est-il qu'à l'époque tout
semble tenir le nouveau bâtiment est
terminé en seulement 6 ans et respecte
parfaitement les exigences du
commanditaire une structure
rectangulaire à la géométrie parfaite
une superficie supplémentaire de 2000 m
car le tout orné de centaines de
sculptures c'est l'élégance la
maîtrise la rigueur une répartition
quand même très mesurée de de l'ornement
une vraie leçon de maîtrise de la
géométrie chantilly est prêt à recevoir
et à éblouir les plus grands rois
d'Europe